chefreporter maximilian kiewel du hast
damals die suche nach engelberg geleitet
was kannst du uns sagen was er meist mit
dabei genau also man muss sich das
einmal vorstellen das ist ja ein
verbrechen gewesen wie im horrorfilm ein
kleines mädchen läuft in den wald und
kommt nicht wieder raus ich war damals
ein paar tage später mit einem
ehemaligen mord ermittler dort am tatort
dann habe ich natürlich gefragt wer
kommt als täter in frage was kann hier
passiert sein
und ja damals schon dinge gesagt die
eigentlich heute spannend sind der hat
gesagt wenn man sich statistisch anguckt
wer kindermörder ist dann weisen 85
prozent von denen eine regionale nähe
einen regionalen bezug zum tatort auf
warum weil sie sich dort natürlich
auskennen weil sie risiken einschätzen
und abschätzen können kriminalisten
sprechen von anker punkten und wir haben
gerade gehört die und schott die sec hat
gerade gesagt
der täter der tatverdächtige jetzt hat
sich dort in der nähe bewegt also da
gibt es anhaltspunkte die sicherlich für
die kriminalisten jetzt spannend sind
du warst ja auch bei der groß angelegten
suche dabei wurden denn irgendwelche
spuren gefunden damals also die polizei
hat mehrere tage wirklich diesen wald
durchkämmt dafür muss man wissen das ist
ein unglaublich dichter dunkler wald
wir waren im hochsommer damals noch mal
da trotzdem war es darin düster und kühl
und was ich habe damals mit dem mit dem
leiter der soko gesprochen und er hat
das noch mal erzählt 45 tage haben die
also gesucht und in der ganzen zeit war
in gastfamilien noch dort und hat das
sozusagen begleitet ja damals hatte das
hat uns doch mit motiviert da waren
teich es gab keinen anhaltspunkt
trotzdem haben wir den ausgepumpt und
dann nach 45 tagen musste dann der
soko-leiter zur familie gehen und sagen
wir haben keinen anhaltspunkt eure
tochter ist nicht hier hat damals das
war ein tag und moment den bitte nie
vergessen und er hat damit der familie
auf versprochen wir werden alles tun und
nie aufhören eure tochter zu suchen
2015 fehlt jetzt von inga jede spur
jetzt könnte es hoffnung geben dass die
eltern vielleicht gewissheit bekommen
wenn tatsächlich sich herausstellt dass
christian b etwas mit dem verschwinden
zu tun hat hattest du auch kontakt zu
der familie und die familie hat sich
damals erst mal zurückgezogen
verständlicherweise es gab bei mehrere
kinder hatten auch kinder mussten ein
neben weiterführen und für die familie
war es aber trotzdem wichtig dass weiter
medienberichterstattung für stattfindet
warum damit das bild in den medien
bleibt damit es doch wenn sich jemand
der inhalt ach ja da war dieses blonde
mädchen doch moment dass das weiter
präsent bleibt und jetzt sitzt mal ein
paar jahre später wieder hier und
unterhalten uns wieder in einem fall und
hoffentlich gibt es eine spur gibt es
denn anhaltspunkt dass auch dieser fall
jetzt geklärt werden kann